everyone loves a good Easter it unless
you're lactose-intolerant
in which case pop culture Easter eggs
are a fading substitute Easter eggs are
those little nuggets of fanservice show
creators include for those fans with
waiting way too much time on their hands
and wouldn't you know it my hands are
covered in time right now so enter
Dragon Ball super whether you love it or
hate it this little series has jammed
itself full of obscure and some not so
obscure references to its parent show
Dragon Ball Z as well as the occasional
pop culture reference or two what's that
don't believe me well you're in luck
because today I'm bringing you the 15
best Dragon Ball super
Easter eggs number 15 Dragon Balls
walking punchline otherwise known as
Yamcha since his cremation at the hands
of a Cyberman in the late 80s has thanks
to the internet reached maximum meme
capacity you can even get a freaking
statue of his death
clearly Toei was in on the joke too
because in episode 70 of Dragon Ball
super otherwise known as the baseball
episode young Jeff finds himself
completely physically mismatched with
the likes of Vegeta on the opposite team
filled with nods to dr. slump it's clear
to see that this episode is purely a
gift for the fans the episode reaches a
satisfying climax with Yamcha assuming
his most famous pose a cheeky nod to any
longtime fans of the series only this
time instead of it resulting in his
death he reaches home base winning the
game for his team
fantastic moment and awesome to see
Yamcha finally get a win
go yaaaa number 14 I don't particularly
like to talk about a kid looking for
tail often or at all really but episode
88 of Dragon Ball super made me do just
that thinking back to the Saiyan saga of
Dragon Ball Z many fans would remember
kid go on chasing a certain dinosaur
hoping to slice off a portion of its
tail to cook for dinner
fast-forward to Dragon Ball super as
piccolo and Gohan train in preparation
for the tournament of power they decide
to spend some time together in a very
nostalgic familiar setting I just hope
it wasn't the same dinosaur poor thing
hardly had any tail as it was number 13
this one I almost missed entirely it
goes by quite fast sticking with the
same arc we land on episode 76 as Goku
and krillen take on an army of
villainous illusions in a forest with
just the most inviting name backed into
a corner by an imposing illusion of
nappa Crillon pulls a Crillon by kicking
nappa square in the jaw and yeah that's
totally pulling a Crillon because he
nails him with the exact same
he did in the saying sock a lot of these
are references to the say in saga I'm
noticing number 12
sticking with the cruel man himself we
arrived in episode 20 smack dab in the
middle of the Resurrection earth park
you know everyone's favorite in this
episode Bulma attempts to gather the Z
warriors in preparation for the
impending arrival of Frieza
and so while chatting with Crillon this
happens do you hear that if that sounds
familiar then you must be a one-piece
fan or at least Crillon is because that
ringtone is a theme song from one piece
fun fact the Japanese voice of Crillon
is also the Japanese voice of Luffy from
one piece number 11 you know Mosca was
always the god destruction I liked least
it could have been his doofy voice can't
wait for the English dub of that one his
weird arms or maybe a combination of the
two I could never quite put my finger on
why turns out Moscow is their
amalgamation of a shitty GD character
called lute just look he's taken his
eyes that stupid belly button plate
thing he has the exact same hands pretty
much everything down to the color is
copied from this character all this time
I wondered why I didn't like Moscow and
it turns out it's because he looks like
a fat guy and shitty GT cosplay number
10 with the commencement of episode 77
so too came the beginning of a brand new
arc we pick up with Goku who by all
accounts is doing great work actually
cashing in on the crops he produced
since the ending of the Future Trunks
arc he seems to be doing quite well for
himself
however on his way back from the market
he gets ambushed by some thugs looking
to rob him in response Goku does this
[Music]
look familiar well it should because
this exact same thing happened at the
beginning of Dragon Ball Z with his
brother Raddatz you know what they say
like brother like brother that doesn't
sound right
number 9 episode 30 wasn't exactly the
most exciting episode to watch but it
did have a neat little Easter egg with
majin buu and another Majin you might
not be familiar with you'll see while
Goku Crillon and Vegeta are trying to
convince Buu to join the team to fight
universe 6
Buu is reading a comic and this isn't
some random comic it's one written and
drawn by Akira Toriyama himself entitled
nickel Majin a manga series produced
between 1999 and 2005 number 8 in Dragon
Ball Z when the mysterious super saiyan
from the Future Trunks arrived it took
many a Dragon Ball fan aback though when
Goku arrived he quickly took the wind
out of his sails as Goku tends to do and
if you thought things would be different
in the future trunks arc of Dragon Ball
super a whopping 216 episodes later
you'd be very very wrong once trunks
arrives back in Goku's present timeline
in episode 49 he wants to test his
strength during the confrontation before
Goku does this using only his fingers he
stops trunks his blade right in its
tracks even smiling at him as if to say
that we've been here before haven't we
number 7 swinging right back from
episode 49 to the very first episode of
the series we all remember mr. Satan was
trying to hand over 100 million Zeni to
Goku as a thanks for doing all the work
against majin buu but what you might not
have noticed was the illustration on the
money in the case you see that weird
robot thing right there that's not
random that's actually a drawing Akira
Toriyama would use to depict himself in
the manga series for Dragon Ball he's
plastered all over it good old Tori
bought a really nice nod to the series
creator number 6
sometimes I'm faced with symbolism that
I just can't ignore and while this might
be a bit of a stretch I couldn't help
myself but to include all the same
featured in episode 46 the finale of the
short-lived filler story known as the
boot arc Vegeta is shown to be using a
pacifier to stop his body from fading
away as rapidly as it was if you don't
know the story it's complicated
check it out it's pretty cool but those
images of Vegeta with a pacifier I can't
help but think is a subtle nod to baby
from Dragon Ball GT this would might be
a bit out there but I love it all the
same number 5 fast forward now to a more
recent episode and we find ourselves in
the middle of a clash between ultra
instant Goku and kefla during the
tournament of power in episode 116 apart
from being a fantastic fight from
beginning to end this episode also
featured this moment blitzing forward to
strike Goku Katla's blow misses entirely
while Goku appears to have not moved a
muscle
if this doesn't look familiar to you it
should if you've seen Dragon Ball Z that
is feature towards the end of episode 66
during the Namek saga goku is seen or
should i say not seen dodging an attack
from raccoon
resulting in raccoon regaining his
bounds in a very similar fashion to
kevlar this exchange is too similar to
not be a callback at the very least to
this moment number 4 from a later
episode back to one of the earliest we
find ourselves an episode 2 of super now
there's the obvious Vegeta keeping his
promise to trunks that he made back in Z
I could do but that's too easy
let's look at this word instead through
the intentionally rough path Puma took
to the resort Vegeta atop the roof finds
himself looking a little disheveled to
say the least if you look specifically
at what's in his hair you'll notice two
types of fruit commonly found in Japan
these two fruits being a durian and as a
Bandhan these just so happened to be the
two fruit that czar bon and dodoria were
named after two people Vegeta killed
while on Namek number three the next
three entries on this list are the most
subtle and I love them all the more
forest beginning with this
reintroduction between two one-time foes
Android 17 and piccolo in episode 94 I
wouldn't be surprised if this flew under
the radar for many viewers it did for me
as Android 17 is approaching the capsule
core building he stares down piccolo who
removes his head where in response to
this Android 17 begins to roll up his
sleeve this is mimicking the exact
movements he made before they fought in
episode 148 of Dragon Ball Z it not only
acts as a nice swerve for those in the
audience that picked up on that but also
adds an extra level of psychology to the
script giving more reason as to why
Android 17 looked amused by Piccolo's
peace offering extending his hand number
2
one thing fans might not have noticed
about the ending to resurrection F is
much it mimics the original fight that
took place on Namek except for the
ending but we'll look past that if we
think back to the fighter Namek we
remember Vegeta being shot through the
chest being stomped on laying in a heap
looking for help and Goku's arrival to
lend a hand in the resurrection F fight
the exact same beats are hit in that
order but with the roles reversed goku
gets shot through the chest gets stomped
on is left in a heap looking for help
ultimately leading to vegeta showing up
to aid in the situation this is a subtle
inclusion that I didn't pick up on my
first time viewing but one that makes
the scene all the better when you see
the parallels now before we move on to
the number one spot let's take a look at
some honorable mentions
number one I had to save my favorite for
last episode 94 for many will be
remembered as the episode that had the
best Frieza transformation in the series
but for me it's special for another very
subtle reason while waiting for fortune
teller Baba to return with freezer from
the other world we the viewers see Goku
for the first time in decades outside
her place sparing one would think with
no one however when put side by side you
can clearly see that he is reliving one
of the last times he saw his grandpa
Gohan it's inclusions such as this that
tells me Dragon Ball super has some
fantastic people working behind the
scenes on the show occasionally
sprinkling it with tidbits of history
and lore that we can all appreciate if
we care to look these were my favourite
Easter eggs from Dragon Ball super leave
me know why yours were in the comments
down below did I miss any if you're new
to this channel I upload every week so
feel free to subscribe for more content
such as this as always comments and
ratings are very much appreciated but
that will do it for this week thank you
so much for watching